for today's first video i'm going to be
talking about
some of my games i picked a couple
interesting ones from
recent um well
i can't say recent tournaments from my
last tournament over the board
um last time that i had this class i
talked a lot about
um us championship and after that i
kind of had so many games of the week
that i decided to
to have a longer stream about it but now
i will go back
to two games from last year's u.s
women's championship that was
that took place online i have
two interesting positions that i hope
you guys will enjoy and then i have
um we'll see how many games we can go
over but i have
prepared two games that i played against
two grandmasters i will not let you know
which ones those are but
we'll see how i did so without further
ado
let us get started it's so great to see
all of you here and i really hope
you guys will enjoy the videos
um don't worry it is
actually uh what it's 2 30 a.m here
where i am
in romania so um hopefully it will turn
well
let's get started all right
okay so for the first position
for today's class i decided to talk
about uh
an interesting game that i had i believe
in us championship last year
i haven't had such a great turn in the
event
online chess is not one of my favorites
especially if it's
such an important competition it's
already a stressful one you really want
to do well especially if you've done
well once and then obviously it's going
to be
um it's
it's going to be more difficult when you
play online and there is even more
pressure
but anyways uh at this point in the
competition i remember i played
irina in round 10.
and she was close to winning the
championship at this time but i had the
white pieces and i thought i got a
really good position
um if we evaluate this position we can
see that
white is a little bit better developed
i have yet to castle but black has
chosen
urina has chosen to play v5
very soon arena crush eight time us
women's champion
super strong player and the only female
who is a grandmaster in the united
states
hopefully we'll have many more coming
soon as well
um and her
my result against her is definitely in
her favor
and in this game i thought i have
nothing to lose at the time in the
standings i wasn't doing so great and i
thought
okay i don't have anything to lose i
better try my chances but there wasn't
such a wise decision
uh at least not chess wise
psychologically it was i think the wise
decision to do
but if you have a similar position it is
very important to make
a good evaluation to try to understand
what's happening on the board and
if you have a clear mind you probably
would not make the move that i chose to
make
in this game but um
so so a very normal move here for white
is to play queen e2
right so you're trying to finish your
development and you can choose to cast
alongside i actually
would have loved to play that i don't
know why i didn't do it but
blake we need to cast alongside and then
wait and see how black is going to
finish
her development because basically with
this pawn in g5 it's not going to be
easy to castle
shore castling will often allow knight
takes g5 and then queen h5
taking advantage of the fact that the h
file is open
and then long castling is also going to
be a little bit tricky
for black eventually that's what she
should do but
it's definitely going to be a little bit
tricky so basically in the position
black
got the chance to win the bishop pair
but has weakened the king side and is
going to make it difficult for her
um in this position i think the game
could have continued
queen c7 long castle maybe bishop g4
or something of this kind and then i
could go king b1 which is very
natural and then if she chooses to cast
a long cocaine
that's uh going to maybe lose the f7
pawn so she would have to maybe just go
to d8
right and okay i can try to
avoid the pin a little bit
put some pressure in c5 maybe she plays
b6
and you know it's a pretty balanced
position
uh black sting is still in the center we
have
um uh
she has the bishop here but she cannot
do so much with it
it's pretty balanced you know but
basically
what he chose to do in this position is
psychologically as i mentioned to you
to you guys before psychologically i
thought i have nothing to lose
she does have some things to lose uh you
never make your decision based on who
your opponent
is necessarily but more like how the
standings are so if your opponent is
your friend
um you shouldn't uh you shouldn't uh
take that into consideration i believe
especially if it's such an important
competition
so you have to try your best whatever is
best for you right so
i thought you know what she has weakened
the position we're playing
rapid chess so i have the most
chances if i create an imbalance in the
position
and i think psychological one wise it
was a good decision as i mentioned
previously but just wise not so much
and i chose this game to show you that
you have to be confident in your choices
sometimes it can work
so i went for knight takes g5 pawn takes
g5 and now i took in h8
bishop takes h8 and the whole idea was
to sacrifice the knight for a pawn
because afterwards i saw that i have
queen h5 coming in
attacking all these pieces and
i thought i would try to take advantage
of the fact that her king is in the
center
now the best move for black would have
been king to d7
because after this move she's basically
protecting her bishop she lets me take
whichever pawn i want
and her king can try to hide on the dark
squares she has to do this definitely
because
if he does not do this um well you will
see what could have happened something i
missed
but uh but
if she she would have played this really
i don't have that many
chances here because if i castle for
example she can go king c7 i don't have
quite a good discovery
here i probably should take one of the
pawns to get something back
uh but then she could maybe go bishop d7
just proceed with her development i have
the chance to win another pawn probably
but
the this is going to be really valuable
given that the fact that my pawns are
not
very much advanced but this would have
been probably the best defense for her
it's not so easy to make this decision
however because if you feel that you
still have the chance to castle and to
bring your king to safety
maybe you can wait for that and she
thought
the best move in this position i i
believe since she played it
was bishop f6 right so the bishop was
under attack and she thought if she's
going to play this probably
she will be totally fine because after
queen takes f7 she's going to
at that point move the king right it's
always you're always thinking
as a player always thinking why would i
do this if
when they do this i can do this i mean
you know but move orders are very
important
in some positions and this was one of
those positions where move orders would
have been
amazingly important what i want you guys
to get from
my miss mishap let's just say in
in this game is that i knew how
important it is for me because i did
sacrifice a piece i knew how important
it was for me
to keep my opponent's king in the center
and
unfortunately i haven't fought enough
for it
i've made a mistake in taking an f7
right now
instead of that i should have cast off i
didn't understand myself
the the problem with the order of the
moves being so important
if i would have castled in this position
basically now she cannot go
king d7 anymore she cannot just run away
because i simply
play knight b3 or knight f3 either one
of these moves
and she's going to lose the queen right
uh she can of course play bishop d4 or
94 but we'll just take the piece we have
uh you know we get the piece back a
bunch of pawns are going to be falling
as well
and black's king is still in the center
so obviously that's not
a wise uh a wise decision for black
six could be a choice because clearly
after castling i am threatening queen
takes f7
she could also go maybe 95 one of these
two moves was
something that i had in mind and i
thought she could kind of save the
position and then of course you can
king d7 which we have already seen
uh so in this position uh for example if
she plays e6
this is a move that i think i missed in
the game and i didn't really
realize that i would have sufficient
compensation in this position
the point is that after e6 black is
blockading this bishop in c8
and she's not doing so much to bring the
king to safety
at least not not exactly in my mind when
i
considered this move because i did
consider trying to keep her king there
and not help it
hide away in c2 i thought that i don't
have a good discovery for my knight so
at first i thought okay if i play knight
b3 she's just gonna move the queen
and then you know maybe i can take here
but then you know her king could only
stay in e7
everything is protected she's got the
bishop what am i going to do
and i was right this wouldn't have been
the right decision for me
uh knight f3 also doesn't do so much so
because i considered those two moves and
i felt that
okay my discovery doesn't do anything i
abandoned my idea and that was wrong
you don't always have ideas
that uh finish
with with something immediately right
you don't always
have a clear finish especially if your
opponent's king is in the center and it
you can find a way to keep it there
sometimes you're sacrificing material
and you have this positional advantage
you have
to play dynamically you have to find
ways to make moves with tempo
and that is something that i haven't
considered and i felt that i had to do
something immediate if i wasn't doing it
immediately i stick
i would have stayed with a piece down
and that was a wrong
thinking process instead of that i
should have considered
this move f4 this i think would have
been a really nice
idea and it's making black's life very
difficult because
now what we're trying to do is push e5
we're trying to get a little bit more
space and in the same time
uh create a better location for this
discovery
that the night after 94 could go to d6
or f6 but definitely d6
is a much better choice putting more
pressure in f7
and my opponent would have struggled i
believe a lot here to find the right
placement of the pieces
for example if she goes with the
you know development for example queen
e7 to keep c5 pawn protected and c7
and then escape with the queen from the
discovery we could push e5
the bishop would go back and then knight
e4 of course
followed by knight takes g5 and even if
i don't have
all the material back i have a pretty
good
position i have a pretty good position i
have quite a lot of
compensation as she goes bishop d7 i can
take the pawn
and it's still not easy for black to
castle if she does castle i'm taking an
f7
i will have technically the same amount
of material back right three pawns for
the piece
and the game could go on and something
else that's very important her bishops
would be restricted
usually of course when someone has the
bishop pair the center
has to be opened and then those bishops
would do
you know an amazing job but here her
bishops are restricted by its own pawns
and then this dark square bishop is
restricted by mine
i have a beautiful chain of pawns
despite the fact that the pawns are
doubled
i mean that's the only bad thing but
after that my knight will be able to
come back or i could take like i said if
she castles
and uh definitely i would be having
plenty of compensation
as i said i i think this would have been
very difficult for her
to meet especially in a rapid game
psychologically
and basically you know over the world
you can clearly see how simple white's
moves are and black cannot find a way to
really stop and do anything
this pawn has to stay in e6 to not to
lose f7 so e5
is not a choice and yeah
f4 this is a move that i missed
unfortunately
95 as i mentioned was the alternative
for black to
protect the pawn in f7 and then attack
my bishop i have seen that this move
does not really bring black much success
because they
have this discovery in this case and
um and after knight of three
she does not have a good place to move
the queen if she
moves the queen to c7 obviously i'm
going to take here
and uh you know you can already capture
queen takes f7 mate and if you play e6
okay
we have so much extra material we can
always you know go back 94
and we don't have so much we have an
extra pawn
but black skin remains in the center and
that's pretty bad
um okay someone was asking about
96 96 is just a check we are trying to
get some material back too we don't want
to just give checks
we we try to get some material back too
while in the same time keeping the king
in the center
so material will be important as well so
we cannot really
let it stay you know we cannot stay with
material down for too long because after
that
it will be an issue if she does
sacrifice the queen that she could
considering that she does have quite
some material will go king takes d1 of
course and after knight takes c4
in this position you need to spend a
little bit of time to understand
how to get the material back but i think
knight takes g5 is fine
followed once again by f4 trying to hold
on to the knight
try to push the pawns depending on what
he does as well
b3 as well chasing the knight away and
black is still going to struggle to
protect the f7 pawn
but this would have made her life very
very difficult she's made a mistake
so did i but really i would have gotten
a really really nice position
all right uh and so after
after that move she
after this move i chose to play queen
takes f7 this was a mistake
for me because i'm actually instead of
keeping her king in the center even if
i'm uncastling her
i'm actually helping her bring the king
to a safer location
the c7 square is a safer location and
it's helping black get rid of problems
so this was definitely a mistake for me
i thought i put it um not clear
i i put it blunder because i feel like
i'm going from a position where i could
have
the advantage to a position where
not so much d7 my castle longer now king
c7 and as i mentioned
now my discovery does not do so much
i did try knight b3 in this position and
she found a beautiful move
here and that was 95. i felt that i have
lots of
choices here i felt that she had to go
queen h8
with the idea of course the queen was
attacked i thought she had to go there
maybe she would have had some sacrifice
ideas but
i was thinking maybe bit up here and
[Music]
and try to at some point take the knight
i was having ideas to take in c5 at some
point
but obviously i had to be careful so she
doesn't take in c3
so i did have a few ideas on how to
maintain
my um uh
you know my strong strong
uh some a little bit of attack and i
would keep her from finishing her
development
but she's still better here however the
move that she found which was 95
clearly gave her a better position and
that was a move that i missed because
given the fact that she has the extra
material and her king is still in the
center
for her it is amazing to trade pieces
because then her king will not be
in danger anymore so after this move i
could go um
luke takes the eight this should have
been my choice
i've made a couple of wrong decisions
and then step by step she was able to
finish her development
and that you know her position just got
better and better and eventually
she ended up winning this was my last
chance
and you just go for a pretty long line
that
the engine uh you know still gives
advantage for black there but this would
be the best choice
for me so trading the queens and then
now obviously
you know i cannot just move the night
uh sorry the rook somewhere randomly so
i would have to take
rook takes e8 and then i would take an
f7
and here because she has an exchange up
she needs to try to find a way for her
look to get active
it's very important for blackstroke to
get active
because otherwise she cannot really show
the advantage of
exchange so she would probably go here i
would need to move my bishop and then a
nice move
the computer finds two i actually saw it
in the game bishop e5
idea is she's attacking f2 and then if
you play f3 for example that pawn will
be hanging
obviously i could try to play to take
there but if i do let
the rook on second rank it's gonna be
game over for me
so my best choice according to the
engine
and to me too is to play a four and now
to try to take here because obviously
speaking is just helping black right you
could take with check
defend this pawn and then it's gonna be
game over
i can try to play this move but um she
has
she has a beautiful f3 move here
that actually helps her get the rook
active after which
i think black is going to have big
chances to win the game this is a strong
move because
obviously 96 does not do so much the
king just moves and
and after the trade route takes i cannot
take the rule because f takes g2 and she
promotes
so this would have been my best choice
however in this position
somehow i thought i needed to move my
queen i didn't want to trade queens
i felt that keeping the queens on the
board could give me some chances
unfortunately it didn't to queen h5
she went for the queen trade obviously
she needs to move the queen because it's
still attacked she cannot take the
bishop
but she went for the queen trade i had
to retreat and as you can see going from
that position where i had so many pieces
that i could attack her her king would
have stayed in the center
now the king is safe he played b6
protected there and the next few moves
are quite
simple as to what black wants to do
either before b7 or
trying to get it out in g4 but b7 makes
a little bit more sense maybe rook d8
trade and black is just having a great
position
i played on a little bit longer hoping
for one blunder so that i had
some ideas to get into play and maybe
get a perpetual
but she played this nice move rook b8
she did not rush to
develop the bishop this would have
allowed me for a beautiful
would have allowed the beautiful maybe
perpetual and then queen b5
and then if i get to take this pawn or
you know it depends
i probably don't take it immediately i'd
go queen a5 queen e6 depending on how
black was the king
and just get a perpetual i really wish i
did have that idea but no i didn't have
it because after bishop d5 she played
ruby8
and from here on it was just a matter of
technique
she slowly pushed me back and eventually
won the game
so i did show you this position because
i thought it is important for everyone
to understand
from my mistakes i don't mind sharing my
my
uh mistakes uh
i think when i share them i acknowledge
them more too so it's kind of like
one of those pro processes where you are
not only helping others you're helping
yourself too which is
amazing uh so so i felt it was important
to remind you that
if you do choose some kind of a
psychological approach in a game just
remember
what your idea was in the first place
and make sure you follow through with
that
and always consider move orders
and if your opponent's king in the sen
is in the center make sure
you make the decisions to keep it there
the best possible way you can
all right the next position that i have
is actually an end game
that it was from that same us women's
championship
and i thought it was uh it was quite an
interesting game against um
emily nigwen a very talented young um
girl and um i
i'm i'm kind of happy i felt that it's
it's a nice position i did show this
position before not on
on a stream but i feel that room
and games are those types of end games
that we're not so sure
about you're told that they're often
draws
and and so on and so forth but you
always have to know what it is that
you're looking for right so
uh you know that it is important to have
a rook act
if it is important to have a king that
is active obviously
uh material could or could not be
important
what is super important are the pawns so
it is super important
how advanced the pawns are and
how you can like in some situations you
may need to give up your rook
in order to to um
for a pawn in order to make a draw so
sacrifice your look for a pawn and then
with the other ones
you have to with your remaining pawns
you have to
support them with the king to to try to
to save the game so that the opponent
sacrifices their rook for the pawns and
draw and i found this to be
kind of like a study like end game and
that's the reason that i chose to show
it on the stream
i thought it's kind of kind of nice so
obviously
i'm in check right now and i have to try
to find a way to win right so
the natural move for me in this position
is king c6 i think for everyone this is
this is a normal move that you want to
play and the question is you know after
white plays this move what is the result
what is going to be the result
of this game should it be a draw should
be winning for white
why am i saying just winning for white
and not winning for black obviously
white spawn
here is way more advanced than these
ones
and uh the white is the only one who
could consider
winning at this point right because that
pawn
is very advanced and
you want to promote it going king e6
does not make as much sense as going to
c6 because
black also has two connected past pawns
and if at some point they do sacrifice
the rook for that pawn and they start
pushing
and they'll sacrifice the rook for it
you want to win this pawn as well so
that
in the end you win with the b pawn
that's why it is very important to put
the king in c6 to win the b6 pawn
and here yeah actually i'm curious if
anyone in the
chat would have an idea
um as to what um
what black should do here
and if black can make a draw
the answer is obviously yes because i've
asked you
um if you're thinking psychology since
that's
something apparently i've been talking
about
and
and black does have a way to make a draw
so the easier way you can think about
the black is to maybe go to king g4 and
try to push the h
pawn so that white would have to
sacrifice the rook for the h
pawn black would sacrifice for that and
then by the time you take the b
pawn the g pawn will go forward and
you'll try to kind of
um change the same time
uh someone is not seeing the board right
we're actually seeing this board from
white's perspective so these pawns do
come
in this direction to make sure everyone
understands
so that's clearly something that black
wants to do
king g4 is a move that could make sense
uh
i could see other other suggestions here
besides king g4 h3 is not the
possibility obviously
but king f6 i saw and then there's one
more that nobody is saying
which is tech these three moves are
moves that black should consider in this
position
provided that they have time actually my
opponent this was a
rapid tournament it was u.s women's
championship
but it was played online because of
coffee right so
it was um it was
um a moment in time where my opponent
and myself we didn't have much uh time
left we were getting long time
and we had to make you know fast
decisions but these three moves are the
most that you have to consider in this
position
so um king g4
does not work and it's going to be
pretty simple i clearly want to push
in order to promote and because the
promotion square is controlled by the
rook
this is going to help me very much to
win the opponent's rook
she would probably go h3 i would promote
to win her rook
and then after h2 it's actually not so
easy there's just one move that wins the
game
you cannot try to win it any other way
but it's clear that they want to promote
so
this is your way to to stop the pawn
king g3
and then white is much more advanced
in this situation because now if you go
for example king g2 we push
and then whether you push g5 or try to
promote to win
the rook we can just move the king and
okay it doesn't have to be c5 but it
doesn't matter because white is way
ahead
right in development in development in
in the promotion
and queen versus the g pawn on second
rank is winning hopefully everyone is
familiar with this
um idea
so going back to that position
uh g4 doesn't seem to work right and
then
we should look at king f6 king f6 was
actually the move that my opponent
played in the game and
it did not work very well for her
because although you're trying to bring
the king to stop my d-pawn
you're simply giving me the h pawn and
after and i probably could have played
d7 too but
it just seems simple in a blitz game if
someone gives you material and you see
that they don't have a way to actually
take your super strong strong pawn which
that pawn is a killer you don't want to
ever give it up
then you should definitely do it and
then it's pretty simple you just give a
check the king moves
i play look back to e8 so that whenever
i push the pawn my rook would control
the promotion square
and black's pawn now is way too behind
and
it's going to be super easy for me right
to win after promoting if rook takes
rook takes the rook will go back stop
the g
pawn i would take this one and then win
the game if the b
pawn actually both b pawns wouldn't be
on the board obviously
you know black would have the chance to
make a draw but unfortunately
for them the pawns are on the board and
it doesn't help
so um so clearly
considering the three moves that we've
discussed the correct move for black
is actually a rook to c1 check
this is the correct move and you know
many of you have not considered this
move because in a way
it's counter-intuitive um
when you are trying to solve a tactic
when you're in the middle game and
you're trying to find a tactical
uh idea you're often told that you have
to look for checks and captures
in end games however giving a check is
usually considered not to be such a good
idea because
you can actually help the opponent's
king get to a better location
and this is basically what could happen
here after
rook two um
to see one because you're thinking oh
wait a second the king
goes to a better location right um
because it can take a free pawn
we're actually helping him take the pawn
and after taking that pawn
if we go back through d1 right because
that's what we should do to stop the
pawn from going to d7
white will go king c7 and now what is it
that we're going to do we just let them
take that pawn
and now this one is passed as well
that's our thinking process
and then if we give them a check they
will go king d8
and then yeah then they play d7 and they
win
in our mind this is usually what we're
thinking however that's a wrong thinking
process because here actually
we are saving ourselves with black the
way we're
saving ourselves is that now
after these checks white has put the
king in front of the pawn
which means that after playing d7
white will have to move the king away
from in front of the pawn then promote
so we have sufficient time in this
position with black to actually go for
this one
so after d7 rook takes b4 white will
play probably
king e7 just you know to promote the
pawn
and then we can go to b7 and then he can
try to go rookie
king e6 or king eight wherever we will
sacrifice the rook and guess what
now we have sufficient time to actually
make a draw because
of uh these pawns so king g4
uh white will bring in the king
obviously we play h3 first
and because the spawn is still on the
board
white cannot really get the chance to to
get the winning position because they
don't have time to win that pawn
um first and then bring in the king so
no matter how they try to bring in the
king black will be able
to save the game for example something
like this
doesn't doesn't seem to work like we
don't have time say here
check king f2
and we attack the pawn king to g2 and
you know the promotion is happening
there's not so much we can do
if instead of this move king king e5 we
try to go king f6 and take the pawn
uh king g3 actually both work king g3r
and then h2 or king g2 k2 for us by
followed by h2 or h2 followed by kg2
there's no way for white to be able to
win this
and the game would have ended in a draw
so this was basically a counterintuitive
idea
and that's why i wanted to show it
because i felt it is like a study
where you are forcing the opponent you
know to keep
you keep moving the king the king needs
to go to protect one of the pawns
you cannot protect both you protect one
of them but
um it's not going to be enough
to win the game if instead of king d8
king g7 the same thing would happen
rugby one and
you cannot really find a way to stop
black from taking this pawn and
sacrificing it for their such a move
will allow black to push this pawn and
you will have to go back um
and be careful not to lose not to let
black make way too many moves with his
king
and the pawn so that at some point when
you actually have to sacrifice it
their g pawn will actually have chances
to win
so rook c1 i found this to be an
interesting game
and i really hope an interesting ending
i really hope you guys liked it
the next game that i want to show you
i'm actually really proud of
it's a nice game that i won
against uh grandmaster alexander
fishbein
and i played this game uh in two
thousand
uh twenty incher blossom or 2018 or 2020
let's check very badly
19. um yeah because 20 what what i'm
talking about 2019 cherry blossom it was
sometime in may
and um i'm pretty proud of it because
you know
it's not often that you beat such a
strong grandmaster and um
i'm pretty pretty proud of the way i
played this game
so let's see how it went so the time
control was like normal time control
right it was an over the poor game
started with d4 knight f6 knight of
three
i kind of wanted to play something out
of theory i remember this was the last
round of the event it was a nine round
event and i had played a game in the
morning
unexpectedly won it it was much worse
for me i was supposed to lose but
somehow my opponent laundered and i won
i was really tired after six hours more
than six hours of play and then
you know i had an hour less than an hour
to eat and i had to play again and i
thought okay i'm just going to play
something that
i have no theory and just you know try
to play chess
visual g7 before i transpose to an e4
opening
which is the perk right i was supposed
to the pir
and i thought i'll just play quiet try
to have some solid position
and see what i can get from from it
he canceled castled knight seasick
um most people in my opinion should go
for c5 here but i
i don't know exactly what he was trying
to get
when you're playing you know the modern
openings you
have multiple ways to attack the center
my opponent probably
was thinking that he would attack it
with e5 that was his idea
but c5 i think makes a little bit more
sense um
i would have played c3 and then if at
some point he would have taken pawn
takes and then my knight is placed in d2
which is kind of bothering
the development of my bishop instead of
having it there which is
definitely a much better location and he
played knight c6 and i i thought for a
little bit of time and i was like
okay he wants to try to play with the e5
he's trying to get the king's indian
position
where my pawn is on c2 i mean i could
play c4 obviously
but my knight is in d2 which is
definitely not play so well
and i thought okay um what to do here i
could
just pretend like i don't care go play
c3 but e5 is going to be the move that
he wants to play next
i was like you know what i'm going to go
for the space i'm teaching
how my students how important space is
trying to get it when you have the
chance why won't i do that myself too
so i play d5 um
and the thing is now that in this
position blackhand has to go back to b8
and
this could have been his idea too um the
knight here
is an option just it's not such a great
option
positionally speaking because after the
trade black's bishop will stay
restricted um i don't have that much
advantage but i can try
to get a little bit more space on the
queen side and
um you know his bishop will be closed
which is something i was hoping for but
no he played 98.
and
then uh i went to rookie one
so um i'm i'm trying to kind of improve
the position of my pieces obviously i
need to make sure this pawn is protected
before i move the knight
so i went rookie one in order to have
the opportunity to maybe go bishop f1 or
and protect my pawn and after that
i would see if i'd go with e5 or if i'd
go c4 c5
but he immediately played c6 he's trying
to attack my center
and um get some space for himself
because he went knight c6 98 so he needs
that knight to go back
into play i was like okay fine
let's see what your plan is next i'm
going to try to transpose to a king's
indian
and let's see how you want to attack my
center
and from here on i felt that my opponent
uh
made i don't want to say bad choices
he's a grandmaster he's a very strong
player
um i think he also didn't really want to
play theory he was trying to get me out
of theory or
knowledge because i played pretty
confident this game i played it pretty
fast
and so i
i was like okay um
i i try to uh to show that i'm super
knowledgeable of what i'm playing but
really it's just natural moves right
just natural development moves
he's trying to do the same thing knight
a6 i think maybe a5 is an interesting
choice here maybe e6 is an interesting
choice
trying to open up the position a little
bit give themselves more
give himself more space here to develop
the knight afterwards
you know and then the knight could go to
c5 but he chose knight a6
and here i remember i spent a little bit
of time and i was like okay
if this would have been i can't seem to
mind i would have been there i could
finish my development but guess what
it's not like that and i need this
knight to move away from there so that i
can
you know uh develop my bishop but i
cannot move it now because that pawn is
hanging
i cannot go queen c2 because maybe some
knight before
i could go bishop f1 but uh i was like
no
so i made a decision that i i'm really
proud of the next two moves that i chose
to make because
um in a way i'm getting rid of my space
but what i'm doing is i'm also kind of
restricting their
the the placement of my opponent's
pieces i took in c6
because the knight moved away right from
there normally
if if i would wait what if i would have
taken earlier
i bet my opponent would have taken with
the knight and then we would have some
kind of
dragon sicilian a maruti
kind of position but here he has to take
with the pawn
and now i went for this move
the reason i'm proud of it is that i'm
trying to mess up his pawn structure
you know and and so obviously if you
would take here
i would take with the knight and then
that pawn would be weak
that one would be a little bit of a
struggle bishop f3 comes in
i'm not sure if i go knight b3 94
and i have slightly better place pieces
and so he chose obviously not to take he
moved the knight back
but you see i was able to move my pieces
forward to advance
whereas he's kind of going back he has a
knight on the edge of the board a knight
on the back rank
look at his most of his pieces on the
back ring i was pretty happy with this
position
uh now i play knight to b3
okay so i told you guys that it was very
important for me to move the knight away
so that i could finish my development
now it was the time to do so and he
proceeded with his development as well
queen c7
um the development of this pitch up is
very important
and i think c5 could have helped him a
little bit but
given that his knight was placed there i
think he had in mind that the knight
would go to c5
so he did not rush with the pawn push
could have been
a good decision i think
queen c7 is what he played and now
i try to take advantage of
his badly placed pieces and make moves
of development each time with temple so
i
took took with the knight
if pawn takes i would have probably
played
one of the knights to i think this one
to d4
because if he ever plays the this i'll
have knight before this will be a
backwards pawn
also bishop f3 that would be an outpost
for me anyways bishop f3 is a move that
i was gonna play
i would develop this bishop i think i
would have had a good position
he chose to take with the knight because
that was his worst place piece and he
was trying to improve it
but now i decided to play against his
1986 so i went c5
also not just against the 19 in a6 i
also thought this pitch up
will not have that good of an idea
of a place to be developed so i thought
if i play c5
i got this he moved the knight and here
someone is saying queen c2 and c5 yes
looks i play c5 queen c2 you have to be
careful when you move it because if you
don't move it
it'll be knight b4 coming in with tempo
and then knight d5
now black has this outpost for their
knight if they get with the knight there
i thought i wouldn't like that idea so i
was trying as much as possible
not to let them do it especially now
after knight five i felt that that was
something
that they could do and i didn't want to
let them so i play bishop d2
i need to finish my development and as i
said i played against their band
bishop c4 was another choice that i
considered
uh but i thought
maybe some knight knight before us was a
choice
i also thought g4 would be nice but i
didn't really want to risk it to weaken
my position just yet
i thought i should develop my pieces
first bishop d2
and and he played e6
so a very nice approach
uh for black or maybe not very nice a
very
an approach that could you could think
about
is bishop takes b2 because you can say
well why did you play that move you're
giving a free pawn
but listen same is my
in my game against the arena crush in
some situations
if you're trying to get some activity
you're trying to play dynamic chess
you may need to give up material you
just need to be ready to know how
your how you will continue that idea
so i thought i would go re1 and then
whenever they go back
i would go g4 and the knight is
forced to go on the rim and then h3
and even if i have a pawn down it's
almost not visible
black's knights are terribly placed and
they're struggling to finish their
development a move like bishop b7
it's not really helping them they just
what is the bishop doing a b7
is just restricted anyways i could go
you know even here and then i oops
not there sorry queen c1 and i think
that knight is trapped
they really they're they're really
having trouble with these pieces they're
badly placed they have an extra pawn but
but because of theirs lacking
development
that extra pawn is almost not even so
possible
so i wasn't worried about the loss of
the pawn he didn't take it either
he also was thinking about how to
develop but as i said it's not so easy
my bishop in e2 is very annoying keeps
the pressure on the knight therefore the
bishop cannot go out
um he played d6
probably thinking that against any g4 he
can also retreat with the knight tear
and then the knight could go afterwards
to d5
and again now it is time to to
take my queen out so that i can complete
my development
but i didn't want to push to place the
queen ec2 because
i don't know i didn't want to place the
queen ec2 it could have been a good
decision
but i thought maybe i think he had queen
b8 or something
and then try to go knight b4 or knight
c7 knight
95 i was like no no no i will not do
that i still need to take the queen
out but maybe i can be a little bit
sneaky so i play queen c1
how was i sneaky well i have ideas with
bishop f4 hey
careful rook b8 will not work knowing
that this pawn is weak i'm protecting it
but in the same time
i have some sneaky ideas with my bishop
i'm controlling the h6 square too so
if i ever consider to play g4 that
knight has to go back to e7
or else it could be trapped i also
thought by the way after e6 i thought he
may have ideas
take advantage of my weak pawn in c5
it's normally not that weak if i ever
get to play b4 but at this point it's
kind of weak
he could try to find a way to attack
with queen e7 and in order to avoid that
um i've already said why he didn't go
bishop b2
guys um
anyways so he play queen queen b7 here
rook b1 bishop d7
and now i win knight a5
had to finish his development and now i
went
1985 with temple the only move for the
queen is ca to keep the knight
protected and now i continued improving
my position as i told you the c5 pawn
was weak
so i decided to protect it and it's
always nice to create a chain of pawns
yes [ __ ] of f4 bishop d6 uh idea is
certainly a very nice one
bringing the [ __ ] up to a slightly
better location also restricting the
rook
his queen is stuck now to protect the
knight he hasn't really made that many
like bad decisions it was just like
pretty normal moves i would say but
given the fact that he wasn't able to
actually get the space
too fast he was forced to make moves
with the same piece more than once
uh the 1986 stayed badly placed this one
in f5
is well placed but it's going to be
chased away from there
eventually and just seems like
i get space even if i traded some of my
space now i'm getting some space on the
queen side
and um this bishop is stuck
and so are his rooks he thought he could
have the time to improve the position of
his knight to bring it to d5
which i told you that is an outpost and
he can try to bring one of his knights
he could have brought the one from uh
from f5 but
this one is good is good too
and uh this was a moment where i decided
it was time
for me to uh
to take the position into my hands and
um and not be scared of anything so i
was unhappy with the placement of his
knights in f5
and i thought i have a way to get rid of
it so i played g4
um in my
analysis i also suggested knight to c4
as a as a nice alternative and then if
he would go knight d5 which is probably
his idea
try to do this um
and then i can try to attack him like
this
uh something else i could do is bishop
c3
and try to trade his defender so that i
can attack
his king
but in the end i played one of my
favorite moves
if you know me well enough if you have
watched my
my personal youtube channel you know how
i've won many of my
games against grandmasters
if you haven't watched it highly
recommend to watch it
g4 is my move it's just like one of
those moves that
it's not so great to play but if you
ever get to play it
it could be a little bit fancy and i
have really good memories from this move
and i was pretty happy i could play it
here too
he played knight here obviously he could
have gone back to
e7 but then i wanted to bring in my
knight there because my knight is also
not doing such a great job there i
put pressure but i can improve it on a
slightly better location
so 94 and i was like okay
he's trying to trade some pieces because
he's lacking space
i don't really want to trade pieces but
this one i kind of have to trade
and then i thought i have taken his
bishop away from g7
so now i can try to attack him if you
would have moved the rook
say here i would have still had the same
idea because now the rook and the queen
stay on a fork
getting my knight there is very nice
bishop f3 is an idea
i also could do a rook lift which is
kind of amazing after g4
and uh and yeah and i thought oh this is
pretty nice
he decided to give up the exchange he
was like no no i don't really
care about the exchange as long as my
bishops get to be opened and i stay with
the bishop player
so he played e5 bishop gf
g7 would have been a blunder because
basically or not blunder but like a
mistake
because this was basically what i wanted
to do rook b3 rook h3
and the queen comes to h6 and it's kind
of impossible for black to stop this
from happening
so he played d5 and obviously i took the
material
and not in all situations you want to
take but in this case because i play g4
and i weaken my king a little bit
he may have ideas to take it so i
thought you know extra
material i shouldn't say no to king
takes
in case he would have taken with the
queen i was planning
either bishop f3 or bishop c4 one of
these two moves
uh and i think i can win even more
material
so he took it the king obviously checked
king g8 and now my favorite idea the one
that i mentioned to you earlier
rook lift rook b3 with the idiot rook h3
and he has no way to stop it bishop
takes g4
wouldn't work because after knight takes
c6 there's no way for black to defend
this move
and so he thought to bring in the knight
this is kind of an annoying move if you
don't calculate
and not sure what exactly is going to
happen rook h3 threatening mate
and now i was expecting my opponent to
play knight f8 to tell the truth i was
expecting him that's why he
brought in the knight there he didn't
get it on the outpost but i have an
exchange up
and at least he has to try to stay solid
he has the bishop pair
tries to protect everything the position
is somewhat closed i thought
he should be totally fine but
he did not go for this um if he had gone
for it
probably i could go queen h4 to make
sure that's protected i could afterwards
you know make sure that that i have
ideas with bishop c4
or um knight c4 first knight c4 knight
there
make sure he doesn't have a5 um
something like this but he said he
played knight before
and i think he he was also getting long
time
like trying to get i mean he was getting
in time trouble he probably thought he's
attacking my rook he's attacking g4
i need to move my rook and he will have
a good
uh position if you guys want to check
out my youtube channel you can just
google my name and
it's going to pop up
i haven't posted on it for a long time
so
i may get back to it at some point but
the videos that i made are there
and you may found find some interesting
game analysis that i have shared
so in this position um i went for
this beautiful idea i'm pretty proud of
i went for this
check and then queen h6 check because
now
black has to move the king on e8
and uh if you would go back to jade
obviously there's mate
so he has to go to e8 and i was kind of
brought i mean there are many other ways
to win this
but i thought this is the easiest one
considering we're both getting a little
bit low on time and considering that i
have the extra material i'm super happy
to trade
and i found this beautiful tactical idea
queen takes f4
he has to take and now i'm utilizing the
discovery on
this file bishop here check
and after bishop e6 i won the queen back
i have an exchange up and thankfully i
also have a way
to trade even more pieces and go for c6
has to go there with rook there i would
have taken c6
rook d6 and now because he's pinned he
cannot go bishop d5 or bishop d7 to keep
the pawn safe and now you know there are
tons of ways to win
i just wanted to make it the most simple
a simple one and i got rid of his bishop
pair
bishop pair can be you know an annoying
something annoying uh to to think about
and here after rook takes e6 he played
rook v8 knight takes c6
and after another you know i don't know
20 moves or so my opponent ended up
resigning i don't think there's a point
to show the game
from here on i just you know thought it
was an interesting
game to share a little bit of psychology
a little bit of
decision making you have to
to try to respect the principles you
have to try to make sure you're getting
your space
i think he hasn't really made a blunder
in this game but
just because he wasn't able to actually
get space
he struggled a lot in the game and i i
was able to kind of
take control over the center keep him
from developing
when i noticed his pieces were badly
placed i tried to to keep them there
and uh turned out turned out to be good
enough
so i had one more game that i wanted to
show but
our time is running out i will not be
showing that game maybe next time
another interesting game against the
grand master will see
what next time will be but for now i
really hope you guys enjoyed it if you
have any questions
i'm happy to take any if there's any
questions regarding this game that i
played
i wonder if any of you
have any
all right thank you so much for watching
please do follow uh subscribe to san
luis chess clubs youtube channel
in order to be notified when we go live
when we're posting videos
uh i do appreciate you guys joining in
stay tuned
for another video that i'm going to be
making shortly i'm going live i'm
stopping this video i'm going live
in a little bit with two of my favorite
games
of this past week
have a good evening if you can't stay
but if you can i'll see you in my next
video
thank you guys